roblox is one of the biggest games in
the world well it's not a game really
it's more like a kid-friendly game
design platform where anyone can make
games and have other roblox users play
them mostly roblox is used by younger
kids where they can play games you can't
find on steam or anywhere else or they
could use it as a way to get into game
development and even make a little bit
of money doing it but according to a
report by quentin smith of people makes
games that kids making roblox games
aren't actually making very much money
at all in fact they might be getting
screwed by roblox
[Music]
all right folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel if you haven't
already and if you aren't subbed right
now then please hit the sub button and
turn on notifications because every sub
really does help okay so roblox one more
time in case you missed it it's
basically a tool where you can design
and host your own games roblox handles
the graphics and stuff you just have to
come up with a game idea and then make
it within robox's interface it's sort of
like a digital game development lego set
you can make anything you can imagine in
theory it launched in 2006 but it really
picked up in the last couple of years
and some have noted that that was
probably thanks to kovit because kids
were stuck at home all day with nothing
else to do but play roblox i guess
roblox corporation the company that
developed and operates roblox is traded
on the new york stock exchange and is
worth approximately 50 billion dollars
now that probably seems like a crazy
amount for what is essentially a game
dev platform mostly used by preteens but
over the last couple of years roblox has
cemented itself as a pretty incredible
platform according to roblox they have
20 million games on the platform and
paid out over 300 million dollars the
people who developed those games as of
december 2020. notably roblox recently
stopped calling the games they host
games and started calling them
experiences because they don't want to
get pulled from the app store for being
a store within a store it's a whole
thing don't worry about it anyway many
roblox experiences game whatevers are
very successful one of the biggest games
in the platform is adoptme which
according to techcrunch hit 1.6 million
concurrent users in 2020. for context
csgo's peak concurrent players is 1.3
million more people in 2020 were playing
adopt me than cs go one of the biggest
esports in the world according to the
roblox corporation 25 of revenue
generated from an experience goes to its
creator but things are allegedly a lot
more complicated than that on august
19th people make games quentin smith
released a video called investigation
how roblox is exploiting young game
developers these kids are not just
hobbyists they're doing real work that
is driving the value of one of the
biggest video game publishers in history
but with a cut that's just one third of
the industry standard and nobody looking
out for their health we had to ask
is the next generation of video game
developers being exploited before
they've even finished secondary school
in this video smith lays out all the
public facts you've already heard but
adds a ton of context from interviews
and investigation that suggests that
roblox might be exploiting the kids
making games on their platform the big
thing to start with is how roblox pays
you out because you don't get cold hard
cash from making a super successful
roblox experience instead you get paid
out in robux the currency that you use
to buy passes to and make in-game
purchases in other roblox experiences
but to complicate things further as
smith points out you don't get to
actually turn those robux into a real
world currency until you hit a hundred
thousand robux which cost about a
thousand usd to buy because if roblox is
only taking 30 of your revenue then any
successful game should still be
generating profit right unfortunately
for aspiring game devs smith points out
two ways in which roblox really
complicates the making profit part of
the whole making games thing the first
thing roblox tells us young developers
is make anything reach millions of
players earn serious cash and then the
next thing it says is
ow well i mean if you actually want
people to play your game i guess you
could give us money but as duplicitous
as it sounds we know this works because
roblox has 20 million experiences made
by its mostly young audience even though
when i spoke to professional roblox
developers they told me that kids should
not expect to make money on the platform
so what smith alleges is that roblox's
marketplace is essentially pay to play
when you open the discover tab in roblox
it shows you the current most popular
experiences and if you want to push your
game up you have to pay roblox to
advertise it and guess how you pay
roblox to advertise you using robux the
currency you get for making a successful
game so let's say you go through all of
this you pay your robux for advertising
your game becomes a hit now is it time
to convert your robux into cash not
quite because as smith points out you
still need to wait until you hit that
one hundred thousand robux before you
can cash out but more importantly he
also notes that while it costs a
thousand dollars to buy a hundred
thousand robux roblox will always buy
your 100 000 robux for
350 us dollars roblox developers get
that 24.5 of a game sales in reality
it's even lower if we look at roblox's
published records we can read that for
every one dollar roblox earns in
bookings only 17 cents make it back out
of the ecosystem to developers according
to smith once you've put your real money
into roblox's system you basically
devalued it forever while roblox can
promise you that you're going to make
cash for making successful experiences
it's never actually going to be the same
amount of money that you put in at least
not if we're going by smith's
calculations in case you got lost
somewhere amidst all the numbers what is
allegedly happening here is that roblox
is encouraging the people who buy robux
to never cash out of their system and
remember the people who are buying robux
are mostly kids and to be fair things do
look pretty generous if you don't cash
out you get a lot of robux for making a
hit but you can't buy a sandwich with
robux you can't buy a new game on steam
with robux you can't pay rent with robox
which is something that a lot of indie
developers do when their games are
successful now again the people
designing these experiences and making
this money are kids roblox boasts about
how they're the largest online
entertainment platform for people under
18 in the world these kids aren't trying
to pay rent with their games they're
hoping to make a little bit of money
after school but it doesn't take a
genius to realize that if the money
you're making can realistically only be
spent in roblox without losing a massive
amount of value the system is implicitly
encouraging you to keep making roblox
games which roblox gets a 30 cut of so
the money train keeps on rolling for
them remember roblox is taking in real
human money when people buy robux to
spend on experiences but the creators
making those experiences that people
want to spend money on aren't being paid
in real money they're being paid in
robux and finding all that out is what
led smith to make his video what makes
roblox money is empowering kids to
become workers with unreasonable
expectations of what they can achieve
on this platform in a way that would be
illegal if it wasn't happening online
roblox did not respond to smith or any
other games media for comment game
developer received a statement in which
roblox detailed the amount of money that
creators have made on their platform
quote specifically for q2 2021 developer
exchange fees the amount of money
developers earned on the roblox platform
totaled
129.7 million up 53 over q2 2020 and up
5.6 times over the 23.3 million the
developer community earned in q2 2019.
through the first six months of 2021 our
developer community has earned
248.7 million and we are on pace to
share half a billion dollars with our
community in 2021 which is around five
times the amount of community earned in
2019. basically roblox is saying that
creators have made a lot of money in
roblox but again if we're listening to
smith's allegations we don't know how
much of that money is real money smith
encourages people to share the video and
put pressure on roblox to do better
unfortunately given the lack of
statements about this that seems
relatively unlikely to happen anytime
soon right now roblox is under no legal
pressure or obligation to make any
changes to their payout structure it
seems that currently everything they're
doing is legal remember game development
is still a super new field lawmakers are
probably completely unaware that
anything like this could be happening
which means despite all the allegations
roblox's current alleged practices are
likely to continue at least until
roblox's stock price takes a hit where
creators rebel on mass
i got an n board for you keith how much
money do you think is in this bag
it was in this i put this in the in the
title card how much money he thinks in
this bag
i know the number
80
80
let me know in the comments below how
much money you think this is if you if
you have if somebody is right in the
comments i'll let you know exactly how
much money is in here or you can cheat
and look at my twitter feed